It's
all done because the ramen shop is no good, but can you tell me the reason why you came here, you're a scientist?
Seriously, hey, hey,
Chrome,
I'm not denying all of scientific civilization.
Actually, even here we use fire and tools
.
Gaa,
just how dirty you are with scientific weapons,
you
don't know.  You,
if you hold out your empty head, you'll have a flame reaction, etc.
I'll guarantee the safety of all the villagers on foot in Guangzhou, to the extent that you enjoy
it.
Yeah
[music]
none
ah ah ah My
resolution hasn't changed at all in front of the falling child
ana
tar I
won't be able to do it
Percy
It's pointless to attack any more Percy
He won't betray rain or ignorance